Now, we're just finishing Volume 13 and we're on January the 28th, 1922. Is that okay?
Now, the messages at the very end of Volume 13 are extremely important. And you could
get my diagram back to me if you're ready.
So the first one is that Jesus opened many founts in his divine will, okay? So, Louisa
said, "I was praying and my sweet Jesus drew me to himself and transforming me completely
into himself," he told me. Now, look at what fusing is, transforming completely into him.
And he said, "My daughter, let us pray together." Now, Matthew 18 verses 19 and 20 says that
if two of you agree concerning any matter, I will ratify it in heaven, okay? That's when
two of you pray. That's Matthew 18 verses 19 and 20. This is January the 28th, 1922.
Volume 13. So he said, "Let us pray together so as to hold heaven in our power." Look
at it. If you pray in the divine will, you hold heaven in your power. Is that amazing?
And we will prevent the earth from falling even more into the current of evil. There's
the power of praying in the divine will. And if you can't pray with other people, you
can pray with Jesus. We pray with him in the divine will, okay? So we prayed together and
then he added, "While on earth, my humanity saw itself as very narrow before the divinity."
That means that he was looking at the limitations of humanity before the divinity, okay? And
since it was inseparable from the divinity because he was divine and human, I did nothing
but enter into the immensity of the eternal will. So here he's telling us that he fused
in the divine will all the time, okay? And because he was divine as well as human, he
was able to open founts for the good of creatures. Now a fount is a source, it's a source of
something. So in fact, since they were being opened by a man-god, I could give the human
family the right. Now the rest of us might open a fount, but you couldn't give somebody
else the right to use it, okay? He could give us the right to approach these founts and
to take whatever they wanted. But you can only do that if you're fused in the divine
will. This is January 28, 1922, volume 13. Therefore, I formed, in other words, he made
the fount of love. Look at the list he's going to give you now. The fount of prayer,
the fount of reparation, the fount of forgiveness, the fount of his precious blood and the fount
of glory. And he's given us, when we fuse in the divine will the right to enter these
founts and use them for God's glory and for the betterment of the human beings, okay?
Now this means that overflowing from him were these founts, okay? So that's John 7 verses
37 to 39 that out of your own heart will flow founts of living water, okay? Living water
means divine grace, of course. Now do you want to know who agitates these founts? In other
words, stirs them up. So as to make them rise and overflow in such a way that the whole
earth will be inundated. Now inundated means flooded, okay? So what on earth could agitate
these founts that he has created and has given us the right to actually use? He said it's
the soul who enters my will. So that's fusing in the divine will. So as she enters, if she
wants to love, she approaches the fount of love and by having or even placing the intention
to love. Now I think that is more than brilliant. You mightn't have time to go down a particular
route, but he says, place the intention in your grand. Isn't it fantastic? Even by placing
the intention, she agitates the fount. Being agitated, the water swelled, overflow and
flood the whole earth. Sometimes this agitating is so intense that the waves, you'd have to
use the word also, rise up high and touch heaven and flood also the celestial fatherland.
So heaven and earth flooded, okay? So if she wants to pray, repair, ask for forgiveness
for sinners or to give me glory, she agitates the founts of prayer, reparation or forgiveness,
and they rise and overflow and flood everyone. How many goods did my humanity not ask for
man? I left the doors open. That's terribly important. So that they might enter with
all ease. He has made it so easy for us to actually access everything that he has done
for us. But how few there are who want to enter. That's his lament all the time, okay?
So is that okay? Enter into the divine will. All these founts are there. You can use them
as much as you want, which is really absolutely fantastic. So January the 30th, 1922. Now his
truths are new creations. Now he repeats this in different ways with different insights
in different parts of this revelation. That means in different volumes. And I just want
to say to you, since you've all been studying, that if you think that the end of study has
come, you've forgotten about it. Because one of the great things to do that will make
you a master of these texts is to compare subject with subject. To compare like he speaks
about the truths as new creations here and go to all the other places where he speaks
about the same thing and pick it all up. Then you've got all the evidence. Therefore you
can speak about this. And that's one of the things that the Lord wants me to get everybody
to do so that you own it. You're not dependent on somebody else because somebody else, a famous
or infamous name, says this is so. It's so because you know it yourself, you've found
it. Do you know what I mean? And therefore you own the text. So there's lots of places
where he does this. And he does this with many subjects as well. Gives it he in different
places and he elaborates on it in different ways. Okay. So Louisa says, as I was in my
usual state, my adorable Jesus came and seeing me all reluctant to manifest and write what
he tells me with such an imposing look as to make me tremble, he starts talking. Okay.
Now what stimulates this message is Louisa not wanting to write. We're in volume 13,
she's no longer permitted any excuses. Okay. And so Jesus has to tell her something which
is vital for us who know this text. He says, my daughter, my word is creative. When God
said, let there be light, there was light. When God said, let us make man in our own image,
man was made in his image. And that was that. When I speak, making known a truth that belongs
to me, it's nothing less than a new divine creation that I make in the soul. Now what
is difficult for us to actually take on board is the fact that when this message is spoken
into us, he's also making new creations in us. And that's why we've got to keep reading
and studying the text all the time. And the more we do that, the more deeply we actually
enter into the message. And just as as when I created the heavens with one single fiat,
I stretched them out and started them with billions of stars. And the incredible thing
is his fiat was just one yes. Let it be. And the astrophysicist and the astronomers
have now come to a very wonderful point, which they call a singularity. That means
a single point. And they know all creation came out of that single point. They just don't
know what was spoken. They just don't know that but they've got so close. It's absolutely
fascinating. And he's saying it here, it all came from this one. Yes, let it be. So much
so, there's not one place on the earth from which this heaven cannot be seen. And if from
some points it could not be seen, it would be a dishonor for the creative power who can
do everything perfectly, of course. And some would say that the creative force did not
have the power to extend everywhere. Now why is he saying that? Because in the same way
my truths, what he's revealing here and what he has revealed in the scriptures, okay,
are more than heavens which I would want to make known to all from one end of the earth
to the other. Just as the heavens are seen throughout the whole earth, he wants all creatures
to know this as well. To make them pass from mouth to mouth like many stars to adorn the
heaven of the truths that I manifested. So here's a big hint that this message has got
to be spread throughout the ends of the earth, okay? If the creature wanted to hide my truths,
it would be as if she wanted to prevent me from creating the heavens. Now he will tell
us you see that he's creating new heavens and stars and he's using all this imagery
about what he's doing in us, okay? So if we don't let this message pass to other people,
he says we're preventing him from creating new heavens and everything in them. It's very
interesting way of putting it, okay? And so by the secret that she would want to keep,
she would dishonor me and if someone wanted to prevent others from looking at the heavens
at the sun and all the other things created by me, so as to make me known. So we were preventing
something so massive we couldn't comprehend it. And my daughter, he said, the truth is light.
Now one John one five, God is light. So one John one five, God is light. John 14 six,
I am the way the truth and the life. So God is light, God is life, God is truth. God is
love. They're all aspects of the same person. So my daughter, the truth is light and light
extends by itself. Now even if you go to some of the oldest manuscripts in the church written
by the saints and the early church fathers, they've all used the same expression that
when you come to sort of understand the scriptures more deeply or understand by going through
prayer, it's called enlightenment. That means you have received the light of truth. They've
used that expression from the very beginning of the church. We called it enlightenment.
You've received the light of the truth. And we even use that expression in ordinary everyday
light. I saw the light, meaning I saw the reality of what was going on. So the truth
is light and light extends by itself. But in order for it to extend, it is necessary
to make it known. Now when he says light extends by itself, it's fascinating if you come down
in the morning and there's daylight. It's a bit difficult at the moment. But if there's
daylight out there, it will have got past the curtains and past the crevices, it will
have got in. If there was the remotius space, it will have got in. Okay, he says it extends
by itself. That light seeks to destroy darkness. So it extends by itself. But in order for
it to extend, it is necessary to make it known. The rest it'll do by itself. Now I find that
absolutely brilliant. If you're willing to tell anybody else about divine will, if you're
willing to teach anybody else about divine will, he says, just tell them it'll do its
own work. In other words, you don't have to be clever doing this. You don't have to be
a no-all. You don't even have to understand all the text. You don't have to understand
the whole message or anything. Just give them what Jesus says and trust the grace that is
in you and the grace is in them. I just want to liberate because the Lord is saying I have
to liberate people to become teachers, you see? And when I asked him, how will I create
teachers? You notice he said, he's got a great sense of humor. He says, everything reproduces
a garden of its own kind. He said, you're a teacher, you've produced teachers, that's
it. He said, that's why I'm using it this way. If you're a doctor, I'd use it in a completely
different way. But it makes total sense, doesn't it? Yeah. And if you're called to teach, then
it's teaching that's got to come out of you and out of your own pupils because pupils
become teachers. I mean, the logic of it is so clear that you'd wonder if I took it so
long to get it. So February the 2nd, 1922, the divine will is seed. Now, this subject
is brought up many times in these writings. So you take the word seed and you'd start
looking up where it was all over the place. Okay. Now, Jesus used the term seed for the
word of God in the gospel as well. Do you remember in Matthew's gospel, the parable of
the sore and the darnal and all the rest of it, it's the word of God is seed. And so
it has to be planted in us and it has to produce fruit. It's fascinating. So he's seeing the
same thing here as well. Okay. So this is February the 2nd, 1922. If you go back to,
and I want you to write this down before you would do any of that, right down January the
25th, 1922, January the 25th, 1922, the truths are divine seeds as taught there. And this
is February. Okay. So it means you only have to go back a small little bit and you find
that the Lord has been teaching in my book, it's only two pages. Okay. That is already
brought up the subject of seed, but you've had a long holiday in between that and this
name I didn't remember, you see. And this is where we've got cross references as often
as we can. Is that all right? So if you don't fully grasp what he's saying here, you go
back to there where he introduced it. Is that okay? And he will, he will bring it up again.
All right. So the divine will is seed. Now in the, in the gospel, he says the divine word
is seed, but the divine word became incarnate and had the divine will absolutely ruling
his life. So the divine will is the essence of God. Okay. And if you go down to the end
of this message to this third last line of the message that is February the 2nd 1922,
and go to the third last line, he says, my will is I, my will is myself. Do you see
it? Yeah. Yeah. Because your will is the essence of you and the divine will is the essence
of God. Okay. So just to see where it's actually going. So Louisa said this morning, my beloved
Jesus came all goodness and sweetness. He was carrying a rope around his neck. Now she actually
describes this slightly awkwardly. And he had an instrument in his hand. Now she's not
completely sure what the instrument is. As if he wanted to do something. And then he removed
the rope from his neck and he put it around mine. So that means wherever's binding, he
was going to bind her. Then he fixed the instrument in the center of my person and with the ruler
with which he made rotate. Okay. Through a little wheel that was in the center of the
instrument, he measured me all over. Now there's plenty in the scriptures about the Lord using
a measuring line to Israel. Okay. I think that must be what I wrote down here, Ezekiel
42 versus 15 to 19. And Zachariah to one. So the first one is Ezekiel 42, 15 to 19 and
Zachariah to one, the measuring line. And you'll also find it in two Corinthians 10 12. When
the Lord takes the measuring line to his people, he's looking for something. And when he measures
the whole people, he's looking for the people doing the will of God. Okay. So two Corinthians
10 12. Okay. So he measured me all over to see whether he would find all the parts of
my person as equal. Now it's very awkwardly put. He's trying to see as the divine will
taken over everywhere that she hasn't kept a little department for herself. We're very
good at it. We might give God two thirds, but then, you know, I have a right to the rest of it,
you know, or we might give God a good bit of our time, but he's not having at all, you
know, so he's trying to find out as she really given everything. He knows already, but he's
trying to teach her something by doing this. He was all attentive on looking at whether the
ruler in rotating would find perfect equality. He's looking for order, the divine order,
you see, that's what it's all about, putting us into the divine order, all of us. I mean,
a hundred percent of me, I don't mean all of us, human beings, it's up for a hundred percent.
And as he found it, that's what Louisa says, he heaved a sigh of great contentment saying,
"Had I not found her equal, I would not have accomplished what I want at any cost I am determined
to make of her a portent of grace." That means that every single part of her being is
given over to the Lord. Isn't that absolutely incredible? Now, he could have said that in
two sentences, but he went through this rotation business because that's why I drew a thing
for you. He's going to talk about the rotation thing. And you have to, can you guess what
the little wheel is? Well, if he talked about, OK, if I'm a little wheel, and if he talked
about a great wheel, which you know what the great wheel was, yeah, what's the little one?
My wheel. It's the little wheel. He was measuring through the little wheel if the human wheel
had really been totally given to the divine. OK. And when he finds that he's absolutely
thrilled because he can make a portent of grace out of her. OK. Now that little wheel,
which was in the center, because it's in the center of your being, seemed to be a little
circle of song. Now she calls everything song. The song is a source of light, little circle
of light. And Jesus gazed at himself within it. Now, if the human wheel really is genuinely
handed over to the divine, you are in the image of God because he made you in the image of
God and he's bringing us back into that order. Isn't that correct? So you should be able
to see it. Just as you can have family members present and you say, God isn't he the spitting
image of him? I mean, we had a family gathering the day after Christmas. And I looked at my
brother talking to his sons and there was one of them in particular. And I said, my God,
he'll never die as long as that fellas born as alive. And then my sister who was sitting
beside me said, but he is in the image of our father. We were actually seeing three generations,
absolutely identical. Three men. It's incredible. And assisting the Jukan, we could see the image
of our father in his only son. And we could see the image of him in one of his sons. He
has four sons. Okay. Jesus sees himself in us when we've handed over to the divine. But
I just want to give you the logic of it. You know, that it's not difficult once you just
illustrated. And so he gazed at himself within it to see whether his adorable person would
appear as whole. Now, as whole means, if you take his attributes of patience and kindness
and love and all the rest of it, if one of them was left out, his images distorted, it's
like seeing a photograph and there's a blot on it. His image had to be whole and complete
so that all his attributes are actually manifested within that little circle. Okay. And since
it did appear, all he did, it did appear, he was all contempt and he seemed to pray.
In the meantime, another little wheel of light descended from heaven, a corresponding one
from the earth. The earth meets the heaven. The heaven meets the earth. Similar to the
one which I had in the center of my person and without detaching its rays from heaven,
they identified with each other and Jesus impressed them in me with his most holy hands
and he added. For now, I have made the incision. I have placed the seal and I will take care
of developing what I have done. Now, just there, I want you to write, see a volume 14,
September 5, volume 14, September 5, 1922, because there he's going to explain the seal.
Here he's just saying, I've placed the seal and you will ask, what is the seal? There
he's going to actually explain it. Now, this is what he does all the time in these writings.
He drops a seed message and he'll come back and he'll develop it. Look at the number
of words we've had already tonight that you could develop in a huge way. So, Louisa said,
I remained amazed and I don't know what that was. I just understood that in order for Jesus
to operate in us, it takes the highest quality. Now, I've put John 14, 21, you in me and I
in you are both completely one because that's what you're looking at here. Otherwise, he
operates at one point of the soul and we destroy it at another point. So, here's the Lord working
on me with humility or something and I destroy it with impatience. So, that's where we can
come a cropper. But you see, because her entire being was really given over to him, he was
not having that problem. Okay. 21. On equal things are always annoying and defective,
she said. And if one wants to place something on them, there is the risk that the unequal
side may let it fall to the ground. Now, that's just her not realizing really what she's
saying to say if something is unequal, it'll topple over. A soul who's not always the same,
one day wants to do good and another way will bear everything and another day will no longer
be recognized. She is indolent and impatient. Now, again, this is what your exercise for
tonight. Beside that, I want you to put CF January the 30th, 1906, Volume 7, because there
in that text, he was saying that if you're not stable in doing good, you won't go anywhere.
And the stability was to be the whole of your being given. Okay. And that's what he's
referring. She's referring to here. She's remembering it. Yeah. And this is Volume 13,
and she's remembering that message from Volume 7. So that's January the 30th, 1906, Volume
7. So I just wanted to introduce you to that new aspect of study. After this, Jesus came
back and having drawn me into his will, he said to me, "My daughter, as the seed is cast
to the earth." Okay. So the divine will is seed. That's what he's talking about here.
In the previous message, it was the divine word. Okay. Cast into the earth. You've got
Matthew 13, the seed zone in the ground. And we're the earth, of course, that the seed
is sowning. The earth makes the seed that is sown, germinate and multiply. My will, which
is the seed, extends more than the earth. It casts the seed of my volition into souls,
and it makes many other images similar to me, germinate and multiply. Well, if you put
beside that, John 10, verses 10 to 16, Jesus said, "I have other sheep that I must bring
into the fold." And so one of the things he does with us in divine will is to open us
up that the rest of the fish have to be collected from the sea or the sheep have to be collected
into the fold, whatever image you want to use. Okay. So we cannot be unconcerned about
the redemption of the world. So my volition makes my children, they're the children of
the divine will germinate and it multiplies them. However, know that the acts on in my
will are like the sun. Everyone takes the light and the heat and the good that the sun
contains. So the acts on in the divine will, everybody's going to get them as well. It's
for everybody past, present and future. Okay. Nor can anyone prevent somebody else from
enjoying the goods without anyone defrauding anybody else, all enjoy it. All are the owners
of the sun. Everyone can say the sun is mine. Now, this is acts on in the divine will. Wonderful
peace here. In the same way, the acts on in my will, more than the sun are wanted and
demanded by everyone. So that would be unconscious on the part of most people. All they know
most human beings, I put my hand on the Tommy and I say, most human beings have an ache down
here. And it says, I want something and I don't know what I want. And that ache sends
some people into drink and drugs and all kinds of stuff, sends other people to enter the deserts
to become saints and it sends everybody to heaven. It depends on how you use that ache,
but that's the beginning of somebody reaching out either to heaven or hell to make a decision
to go one way or the other. It's that ache. That's why he says they all want it. If people
knew what if they knew consciously what they could receive from us, praying in the divine
will, they would definitely want it. You know,
if you read, if you read it, a custom sentence, you made it to yourself, you made it with an ache.
Yes, that's right. If we answer that ache in the right way, that's right. Yeah, this pain
in the depths of, yeah, this pain in the depths of our being. Yeah, and everybody has it.
Yeah, absolutely. Everybody has it. So, so the sun is mine. So the whole human race past
present and future can claim the acts that we do in the divine will and wonderful. So in the same
way, the acts done in my will are more than the sun are wanted and demanded by all the past generations
await them. So as to receive the dazzling light of my will over everything that they have done,
the present awaits them so as to feel a fecundation is a terrible word, isn't it fertilized and
invested by this light, the future ones await them as the fulfillment of the good that they will
do. In some, my will is myself. So the divine will is God and the acts done in my will will
always go round within the endless wheel of eternity to become life, light and heat for all.
So he's introduced the endless wheel of eternity and now we finish volume 13 with this endless
wheel of eternity. And that's the one that I tried to draw. See, could we make some sense out,
but okay. And it's a very important message. So this is February the 4th, 1922. The souls
who live in the divine will take part in the eternal activity of the divine will by going
around within it. Okay. Now, when you get up beyond volume 20, this will become your everyday
food because you're Louisa's talking about it all the time. It's fascinating. So Louisa
says that Jesus came, my daughter, the souls who live in my will. Okay. Are the little wheels
that rotate within the great wheel of eternity? And what I say is think of a Swiss watch and
you've got all these little wheels, but there's one major wheel running the whole thing. So my
will is the motion and the life of the wheel of endless eternity. Okay. Now, as they enter to pray
love operation everything. So this is us going around inside of the divine will. Okay. As we do
this, what I've drawn here is exactly what's written here. Okay, you want to show that to Lloyd
he hasn't seen it. So as they enter into my will to pray, to love, to operate, etc. The wheel of
eternity makes them go around within its interminable circumference. So we're inside of it. Now, when
you get to the volumes over 20, Louisa will say so often, it's endless. It's endless. I don't see
any way out. There's no possibility of getting out now that she was really locked into the divine
will permanently. And it was just her amazement in saying Jesus said, yeah, there's no way out at
this point, because you're living heaven on earth already. Yeah. And so you're living within its
interminable circumference. And since in that wheel, they find all that has been done, must be
done. And all that should be done, but is not done. Look at all the things you're supposed to fill
in all the gaps and fill in all the voids. Okay. So as they rotate, number one, they cast light. So
that's right. On some of these here, you actually cast light. And you cast divine waves. Okay, into
what has been done and must be done, giving divine honor to the Creator in the name of all. And they
redo what has not been done by creatures. Now, you're not doing this consciously, the very fact of
entering and fusing in the divine will, this is being done. You're not actually conscious of that.
You can make yourself conscious of it if you want to, but I prefer to leave him to do his own job.
So and they redo what has not been done by creatures or how beautiful it is to see the soul enter into
my will. That's your fusing. And as she enters, the great wheel of eternity winds her up. I love the
expression because really, it's the image of the Swiss watch you're looking at to make her go around
within its great expanse. And the little wheel does its eternal rounds. Okay. The winding by the
great wheel puts her in communication with all the divine windings. It's the fact that you have
fused, you are put in communication with all that God is doing. This is God's work. This is not our
work. And while she goes round, she does all that her creator himself does is absolutely amazing.
Therefore, they are as though the first and the last be created by me, the first because you can
enter into the very first things that God has done. And last because you also do enter into the very
last things that he has done. Because in going around, they find themselves at the beginning,
in the middle, and in the end, that's a whole history and of all creation. So because of that,
they will be the crown of the whole human family. That's number one. They will be the glory of the
whole human family is number two. They will be the honor of the whole human family. That's three.
They will be the substitution for all. That's number four. And number five, they will be the
return to God of the whole order of things created by him. Isn't that absolutely incredible? That's
why it's actually good to list them. One, two, three, four, five. This is what's being done.
Because as you get used to fusing in the divine will, you may forget that there's something
incredible actually happening. Because we get so used to something that you can just sort of say
it and not realize the importance of what is being done. Therefore, let your rounds be continuous
in my will. So the fusing needs to be continuous. I will give you the winding. He says, you want it,
I'll do it. So he does the work. And you will be ready to receive it, won't you?
Poor Louise was supposed to get that on first hearing. Then he added, you have not spoken about
all the rounds of the little wheel. They see the little wheel of your will. Now this is one of the
things about these writings is that if you didn't know at the beginning that the little wheel was
your will, you get it in the end, because he does actually give it to you. And if you get stuck on
something, just persevere with the reading and it comes up. Okay. The little wheel of your will
does within the great wheel of eternity. You in me and I in you. That's the John 14, 21 thing.
Louise has said, how could I speak of them if they didn't know? And he said, as the soul enters
into my will, even with a simple adhesion with an abandonment, I wind her supposed to make her go
around. So he says, even with the slightest hint that you want to go in, he'll take it as dawn.
Isn't that incredible? Yeah. So one of the things I do, if I'm very busy or my head is too full or
whatever it is, I put my hand on some of the divine will prayers and I say, Lord, there's no possibility
of me going through that. But I would like to do it with you in your will. And so I place the
intention and I leave it there. Walk off. Instead of burdening yourself with something you've actually
got no time to do. Does that make sense? Yeah. It's terribly important to say that, because we have
the we have the terrible propensity to stuff ourselves. And I must say this and I must do that. And it's
got to be sort of me consciously doing it. Otherwise, it's not. He says, no, even a hint. I think that's
brilliant. Yeah. It's even a hint. Even an abandonment, you know,
absolutely, absolutely. And that's what he's saying. Yeah. Because, I mean, you know, in the
middle of your work and everything, you're caught up. And if even for a moment, you just remember,
oh, Lord, I'd love to do that. Go on. Isn't that fantastic? You see, I find it very liberating when
you you accept the freedom that he's giving to you. But I'm always afraid if a person feels I have to
do all the prayers and I have to do all this, because I've actually heard people in divine will
feeling very burdened. Yeah. Feeling I have to do this. I must do this. You know what I mean? Sorry?
Oh, totally. Yeah, absolutely. You don't have to do anything except use yourself in the divine will
and let him do everything. Yeah. But the point is, if you can't, for example, if you can't do an
hour's adoration that just that isn't the time in the day, what do you do? Send your courage in angel
town. He has all the time there is. If it's flesh and then Jesus cooperates with those who love him.
Oh, absolutely. Oh, absolutely. It's like what he says about dying sinners if they even kiss a
crucifix or look at it. He'd forgive them. You know, we just don't give him the credit for being
divine love. Do you know what I mean? But I just want to say that to make sure none of us would feel
burdened because he can give lots of prayers in the divine will. And you might feel, I have to say
half of these are a quarter of these, but you don't have to say anything except I will be done.
Or not my will, but I will be done. So a simple adhesion, I think that's brilliant, isn't it? Or an
abandonment? I wind her so as to make her go around. But do you know how many times she goes round?
She goes round as many times for as many thinking intelligences, for as many gazes of creatures give,
for as many words as they speak, for as many works as they do, and many steps as they take,
they say, wow. So we couldn't even cope with thinking about that. In other words, he's saying that
anything that happens in the spirit, it's instantaneous, you know. They go round at each divine act,
at each motion, at each grace which descends from heaven. In some, they form their round in
anything that is done in heaven and on earth. The rounds of these little wheels are fast and
rapid. Do you see anything in the spirit is very rapid? Why? Because there's no time.
So they cannot calculate them, but I count them all. First, take the glory and the eternal love
that they give me and then to fuse all the eternal good and to give them the capacity of surpassing
everything and to be able to embrace everybody and become the crown of everything.
I don't know how often I've said no, we can't improve on this. You know what I mean? It seems
to get more and more wonderful as you go along. Even remarkable. So there's volume 13 finished
with absolute, you know, lights blazing. Isn't it amazing? But I did want to do that for you
there. I don't always do it, give you a cross-references to say that text enlightens this one and to get
more incision to that, you need to go into that one. Because that's another level of study.
Because there's an amazing number of ways you can actually go at this text.
But I'm also teaching them simultaneously. But because I'm teaching them simultaneously,
I now don't know what I'm quoting. But I was quick enough to say we did that in volume 7.
But it is good. It's good to realize that the cross-referencing actually deepens the whole
thing. Deepens your understanding. Okay, so let's begin in volume 14.
And Louisa says, "My love and my life guide my hand and be together with me." So she's asking the
Lord for help. So I'm going to go down to February the 2nd. Is that okay? What should I say? It's
number four, whichever it is. It's wishful thinking on my part. Okay. So the heading says,
"Love wandering and rejected versus into subs." You have to realize this is divine love looking
for a response from the human race. Otherwise you'll think that Jesus is a whimper. Because divine
love looking for a response from the human race. As I was in my usual state, my always lovable Jesus
has made himself seen all panting. His breath was fire and clasping me to himself, he said,
"Why is the breath fire?" Because it's the fire of the spirit or the fire of love. Okay, it's love.
And the spirit is love. So he told me, "My daughter, I want refreshment for my flames." In other words,
he's looking for a response and he's not getting it. "I want to pour my love out, but my love is
rejected by creatures." You must know that in creating man, I released a quantity of love
from within my divinity, which was to serve the primary life of creatures.
So that they might be enriched, sustained, strengthened, and helped in all of their needs.
But man rejected this love and my love has been wandering from the time man was created. So it's
been wandering since the fall. Okay. And it keeps going around without ever stopping. Rejected by
someone, it runs to somebody else in order to give itself. And as it is rejected, it bursts into
subs of crying. So lack of what they call correspondence here, that word is used all the time. And it
means we say lack of responses. Okay. It causes this sobbing of love. Now, it's a very Italian way of
saying things. We would say that this lack of response on the part of the human race causes grief
and sorrow to the Lord. That's the way we would say it in the Northern territories. But the Italians
are very emotional, so it's subs of crying. Okay. So what you have then in the second verse here is
the lament of divine love. Now, while my love goes wandering and runs to give itself, if it sees
someone who is weak or poor, it bursts into subs and says to him, ah, if you didn't make me go
wandering, if you had given me a place in your heart, you would have been strong and you'd lack
nothing. So weak and poor is spiritual. It's not physical. Okay. So it's not, you're not meeting
just somebody sitting on the side of the street. In other words, he is what we are not. Remember,
in John's gospel, you have John the Baptist saying, I am not the Christ, I'm not the Messiah,
I'm not this, I'm not. And Jesus is everything that John isn't. Well, Jesus is everything for us.
Okay. And so we read in volume 13 that when you give yourself to him from poor, you become rich.
Remember that? Okay. So if it sees someone else who has fallen into sin, it bursts into subs,
ah, if you had let me enter your heart, you would not have fallen. For another whom, it sees dragged
by passions muddied with earth, love cries and subs. It repeats to him. Ah, if you had taken my love,
passions would not have life over you. We would say domination, you know, that they wouldn't be
ruling your life. The earth would not touch you. My love would be enough for you in everything.
So in each evil of the human race, small or big, love has a sub of crying and continues to go
wandering in order to give itself to man. And when in the garden of Gethsemane, all sins presented
themselves before my humanity, each sin carried a sub of my love. We would say a grief. Okay.
All the pains of my passion, each blow of the lash, each thorn, each wound were accompanied
by a sub of my love because if man had loved, no evil would have come. Lack of love makes all
evils and even my very pains germinate. So actually, the message there is very simple that
the one gift that the human race has given to God is something God didn't ever have in heaven,
which is grief. And so here's St. Paul saying to the Ephesians, do not grieve the Holy Spirit.
You see, so that's language we would understand. The sobbing and crying doesn't get to me at all
because I'm not Italian. But we just have to realize what they're actually saying. Okay.
And what Jesus is saying to Louisa here is if the human beings had accepted him,
they wouldn't be weak and sinful and dominated by passions and going down the worldly root and
allowing Satan to overcome them. That wouldn't happen. So this is God's grief. And of course,
it's Jesus's grief because he's the Redeemer. Okay. And then in Gethsemane, all of this came
to him. Now she will tell you as she does in the hours of the Passion, I think. It comes up soon,
I think. Ah, yes. It's there in February nine. The tortured body of Jesus is the true portrait of
man who commits sin. That's the next one. The heading for the next message that Jesus explained
to her that if you look at him on the cross, you're looking at a perfect picture of what the human
soul looks like dominated by sin. Totally a leper from head to foot. Okay.
It's a study as well. That's right. Absolutely. Oh, if somebody had that kind of talent,
it would be wonderful. Yeah, it would be wonderful. Yeah. So he's talking now about now about God
creating the human race. Okay. In creating man, I acted like a king who wanted to make his kingdom
happy, takes a million dollars, euros, whatever you want and makes it circulate. So there you've
got the story of the talents in Matthew 25 versus 14 to 30. And you've also got the story of the
unjust steward in Matthew 18 versus 23 to 35. That's two of them. Matthew 25, 14 to 30 for the
talents and Matthew 18 versus 23 to 35 for the unjust steward. Okay. Remember the unjust steward
wouldn't forgive his neighbor at all. So he makes it circulated or whoever wants it may take it.
However, as much as it circulates, only a few take a few cents. Now he keeps repeating that
throughout these volumes. And you know, if you get to a point where you've got a sufficient grasp
of this material, you'll be able to pick up these doctrinal points. Okay, that he says that in the
entire history of the human race, very few have actually responded to him. Now the king is anxious
to know whether the peoples are taking the good that he wants to do for them. And he asks whether
his million is finished. So he can put in more millions. And the answer he gets is majesty,
just a few cents have been taken. So the king feels sorrow. This is the grief we give to God,
the Holy Spirit, in hearing that his people are not receiving his goods, nor do they appreciate
them. So going out into the Mitzvie subject, he begins to see some covered with rags, some infirm,
some going out among them is the incarnation. I covered with rags, some infirm, some starving,
some shivering in the cold, some are homeless. Any sorrow the king bursts into stops of crying
and say, ah, had they taken my money? I would, I'd see none of them dishonoring me covered in rags,
but rather well dressed. Nor would I see them infirm, but healthy. I would see not one of them
starving and almost dead from hunger. They'd all be full. Had they taken my money, no one would be
homeless. And they could very well have built themselves a room and have taken shelter. In some,
for each misfortune he sees in his kingdom, he has a sorrow and a grief, we would say. And he grieves
over his million, which in, in gratitude of his people rejects. Now very simply, what is being said
here is that we cause the Lord incredible grief when he has given us incredible riches and we're
not bothered. You know, so how many people just turn up for what my one time brother-in-law said
was hatch match in dispatch. They've shown no, no interest in God at all, you know. And so,
however, the goodness of the king is so great that in spite of all this in gratitude, he does not
withdraw his million. So there's the Lord having paid an incredible price for our redemption. He
doesn't withdraw it. He lets it continue to circulate, hoping that other generations might take the
good which the others have rejected. So that he may receive the glory of the good that he has
done for his kingdom. So you can see that he's the eternal optimist. He thinks another generation
might do it. And then he gets disappointed and he said, well, maybe another will try the 21st century
when the 20th century did so badly. It's absolutely incredible. He's the eternal optimist. And he said,
that's the way I work. I will not withdraw my love which has been released. It will continue to go
wandering. It's grieving. I'm going to call it grieving will continue until it finds souls who
will take this love of mine down to the last cent. Now, if you really entered into the divine will,
you're taking this love because the whole 36 volumes is summarized by divine will and love. It's
actually that simple. And in so many of the messages he tells you, love is everything. Okay. So we'll
have to get somebody to do research on love. Okay, he says love is absolutely everything. So
I'll keep it up until I find souls who would take this love of mine. So this divine love is not human
love down to the last cent so that my crying or grieving may cease. And I may receive the glory
of the dowry of love which I issued for the good of creatures. But do you know who are the fortunate
ones who will make the sobbing of my love cease? It's the souls who live in my will. They will take
all the love rejected by all the other generations. And so by the power of my creative will
they will multiply it as much as they want and for as many creatures as have rejected it.
Then will my grieving cease and the shout of joy I would call it will take its place. And love
satisfied will give to these fortunate ones all the goods and the happiness which the others didn't
want. Now in the divine will as you know you're not allowed to pray for yourself. And if you're
still praying for yourself then what Jesus found in Louisa he can't find in you just bit
stare for yourself. Okay. But to some people who have said to me what would happen to me
you know I mean someone has to pray for me and I said well if you prayed for all the past,
present and future you're included. And if you prayed for all the dying past, present and future
one day it will be yourself. I suggest that we have to realize that if you pray for the whole
you're included. Okay. But he says much more. He says if you're praying for all of them and
they've not accepted what you've given to you. So you actually get tons more than you would ever
get by praying for yourself. Yeah. So the emphasis must be love has to go out. Love has to be gift.
So if love is going this way it's imploding it's going to die. Okay. So February the 9th,
1922, the tortured body of Jesus is the true portrait of the man who commits sin.
Some artist has got to pick that up because only an artist can put this across. Okay.
That this is what sin looks like. You're a leper. You're covered in sores and head to foot. You're
you're nailed. You can move. You're this, you're that you're the other. Okay. So finding myself in
my usual state I was following the hours of the passion and I was accompanying my sweet Jesus in
the mystery of his painful scourging. He made himself seen with all his flesh all with his flesh
all torn up. His body was stripped not only of his garments but also of his flesh because
Louisa says that he looked like a shorn lamb which was correct because Isaiah said he wouldn't look
human any longer and his bones could be counted one by one. The sight of him was not only harrowing
but horrible to look at so much as to strike fear, fright, reverence and love all at the same time.
I felt mute before such a harrowing scene. I would have wanted to do but who knows what
to relieve my Jesus but I could do nothing. The sight of his pains gave me death and Jesus
all goodness told me my beloved daughter look well at me because you can look at something
that's that horrifies you and you're not looking at any detail. It's just the whole thing. So he says
look well make sure you see what you're looking at that you may know my pains in depth. My body
is the true portrait of the person who commits sin. Sin strips them of the garments of my grace.
That's the first thing why he had to be stripped naked and I let myself be stripped of my garments
so as to give grace back to him once again. So this whole passage is describing the horror of sin
and if someone really wants to make progress spiritually one of the places you have to visit
is horror for sin. Sin deforms him and while he is the most beautiful creature that came out of my
hands he continuously in the higher volumes calls man my beloved jewel. He continuously calls him that
he becomes from that the ugliest one disgusting and repugnant. I was the most beautiful of men
and I can say that in order to give beauty back to man my humanity took on the ugliest form
look at me how horrid I am. Isn't that incredible? I let my skin be torn off by dint of lashes that's
Isaiah 53 4. He looked no longer human to the point that I could no longer recognize myself.
Not only does sin take beauty away but it forms deep wounds rotten and gangrenous which corrode
the most intimate parts. They consume his vital humours at very ancient languages isn't it?
It's very difficult to find that in a dictionary today. I can't find it. So everything he does
are dead skeletal works. They snatch from him the nobility of his origin and the light of his reason.
He becomes blind and I in order to fill the depth of his wounds let my flesh be torn to shreds.
I reduced all of myself to a wound and by shedding my blood in rivers I made the vital humours flow
back we would say into his soul so as to give life back to him once again. Had I not had the
found of the life of my divinity within me which since my humanity died at each pain they gave me
substituted for my life I would have died from the very beginning of my passion.
There's a very important insight. It was the divinity that kept him alive because when when
Louisa describes the agony alone she says he's dying because losing the torrents of blood that
he lost in Gethsemane and then the scurching was so brutal. We all know that the Roman soldiers
were brutal because they lived a brutal life but we have evidence that many a man died raving mad
under the scourge. Some of them got heart attacks they got all kinds of things to survive a Roman
scurching was nearly a miracle. What is being said here is that he wouldn't have survived it
unless the divinity was keeping him alive they went beyond rationality was just not in it at all.
It was even beyond brutality it was beyond bestiality.
Satan was ruling the Ruth. It's incredible. So he says now my pains my blood and my flesh which
fell off in shreds are always in the act of giving life to man. That's what we pick off when we fuse
and make our acts in the divine will. But man rejects my blood so as not to receive life.
He tramples upon my flesh so as to remain wounded. Oh how I feel the weight of ingratitude now
throughout the 36 volumes he describes the human race as the ungrateful ones. That's why I think
it's incredibly important for us to show gratitude to him. And throwing himself into my arms Jesus
burst into tears. I clasped into my heart but he was crying strongly. What torment to see Jesus
crying? I could have wanted to suffer any pain so that he wouldn't cry. So I sympathized with him.
I kissed his wounds I dried his tears and he as though cheered added do you know how I act? I act
like a father who loves his son very much. This son is blind deformed and crippled think of John
of not John Luke 15 the prodigal son because he describes the human race as the prodigal son.
So the blind deformed and crippled is all spiritual and his father who loves him to follow what does he
do. He plucks out his own eyes he tears off his own legs he tears off his own skin to give everything
to his son. I'm happier to remain blind crippled deformed myself as long as I see that you my son
can see and walk and are beautiful. That's divine that's not human is it? Oh how happy is that father
in seeing his son look with his eyes that's the prayer we pray and divine will isn't it?
Look with his eyes walk with his legs covered with his beauty breathe in my breathing you know
that one and what would be the sorrow of that father if he saw his son ungrateful throwing
away his eyes legs and skin contenting himself to remain as ugly as he was he said that's the
position I'm in. I took care of everything but the human race is ungrateful and causes me this bitter
grief. It's when it's described it's almost unbelievable isn't it? And yet how would you go
out and explain that to somebody down the town? You wouldn't know where to start would you?
Okay so at the end of volume 13 Louisa had to be ticked off for not wanting to
write everything. Okay so now in February 14 this is the last one we'll do tonight. Jesus shows his
contentment when she actually does what he wants. Okay now Louisa has been writing which hasn't been
writing everything as the everything is the beauty wants you know. As I was in my usual state my
sweet Jesus made himself seen all pleased and with an indescribable contentment and I said to him
what is it Jesus? Are you bringing me good news that you're so content and Jesus said my daughter
do you know why I'm so content? All my joy my feast is when I see you right
because they're his words they're creative they're going to give life to millions
and for an entire era not just for now and so of course he is happy and the words are going to
create new life in everybody. I see my glory my life and the knowledge of me that multiplies
more and more being inscribed in those written words. It is the light of the divinity the power
of my will the outpouring of my love that needs an envy beside it because he's actually saying
what is so significant about these volumes because she was given a very unusual new insight into the
working of the three persons of the best of Trinity and the power of the divine will and the outpouring
of his love in the passion. I see everything written on paper and in each word I feel the fragrance of
my perfumes very much the language of the song of songs then I see those written words run
run into the midst of the people to bring new knowledge my outpouring of love the secrets of
my will oh how I rejoice and at this stage it's gone all over the world so much so that I don't know
what I would do what I would do to you when you're right and as you write new things that regard me
I keep inventing new favors in order to repay you and I disposed myself to tell you new truths
so as to give you new favors so he explains to her that if she would write more he'd give her more
and initially she couldn't get that that it depended on her attempting to write something
and she eventually gets it that if she even attempts to write he will then give it to her
and I think it's up around volume 24 where he says to her and you do realize that every word of
this came from me you couldn't have done it because she had no schooling at all she couldn't have done
it at all but she got so used to it at that stage that you know you can use to anything so she
wasn't registering with her until he actually said it you know that's like us the more we study
the more we study the more understanding he gives and the more you pray it the more deeper you go
into it yeah yeah that's the logic of it so that's the logic you're going to get in this next paragraph
which I have an in be on I have always loved more and reserved greater graces for the ones who have
written about me because they are the continuation of my evangelical life the spokesman of my word
that which I did not say in the gospel I intended to say to those who would write about me now that's
very much illustrated in Maria Val Torta okay where he calls her another John
and I did not finish preaching at that time I must preach always as long as the generations exist
now when you look at the prophets of the Old Testament the word of the Lord came to me the more they
opened up to that word and the more they proclaimed it the more they got that's what you have here
as well this is the logic of the thing so the weza said my love to write the truths that you tell
me is a sacrifice but the sacrifice becomes harder and I almost feel no strength to make it
when I am obligated and when they force me to write of my intimacies between you and me
and of the things that regard me I don't know what I would do so as not to put the pen on paper now
Louisa only had one problem with the writing and that is she had to write about her relationship
with Jesus that was the bit she couldn't take I went she heard that was going to be published
she nearly had a bit but you see that if we were not looking at this relationship between
Louisa and Jesus how would we know what to do yeah and if we didn't see where she tripped
up and all the rest how would we know what to do about about tripping up and so while you understand
her pain I would feel the same and at the same time you have to understand it had to be yeah
and the priests were pretty shrewd there that nobody would get this just as a theoretical
teaching but to see it as it actually unfolded would enable you to take it to get it okay
and so Louisa said you remain always aside it's always about me and the strange thing is that is
true no matter how much of that relationship is actually revealed what you're learning all the
time is about how we relate to him yeah that's why we don't put Louisa on a pedestal and what I do
to you and how much I love you and where my love towards creatures actually reach this will push
others to love me so that they too may receive the good that I do to you that's precisely it
so besides this mixing you and me in writing is also necessary otherwise some might say
to whom did he say this to whom was he so generous and lavishing his favors maybe to the wind or the
air is it not said that in my life I was so very generous with my mother that I spoke to the
apostles to the crowds and that I healed such an infirm one therefore everything is necessary
and be sure that whatever you write it is always me that you make known all the time and you make
it known more and more and so I'm good to stop there for tonight it's a quarter past and we'll have